what's your journey go ahead yeah yeah
so I was raised in the Catholic church
and
um I was uh well I'll get to the YouTube
thing later because I don't want to lose
you question that's I was I was raised
in a Catholic church and um I uh I kind
of fell I didn't fall out of the faith I
kind of just slowly drifted away and I
never even knew really what I believed
in so naturally I just kind of um like I
came closer to God I went to BST College
uh I'm not Protestant I consider myself
non denominational yeah uh was it
located in Illinois somewhere no it's in
Charleston actually um but so I consider
myself non- denominational and I don't
mean to take it take any more of your
time but um yeah what's the question
yeah the question is uh do denominations
really matter when it comes to following
Christ cuz I feel like uh
we Bas feeling again huh I'm sorry this
is just how I talk but um no I'm just
saying because even a non- denomination
is aomin it's a denomination it's non-
denominational sure yeah so you're
dividing the body of Christ so does it
matter yet because you're dividing the
body of
Christ so Christ doesn't want the body
to be divided it's condemned in 1
Corinthians 1 chapter 1 ver 10-1 17 1
Corinthians chapter 3: 1-10 it's
condemned so that means
to please the heart of God and to make
Jesus happy we have to do everything we
can to go back to the church that's been
around since the beginning and do
everything we can to bring healing and
Reconciliation to the members that have
broken off because Jesus's prayer in
John 17 read John 17 2023 he says the
world will come to know and believe that
God sent Jesus into the world
by our perfect union with one
another and he says that he wants
Christians to be one as he and the
father are one are there any divisions
in the
godhead no are there any arguments and
debates and disagreements in the godhead
no Jesus says that's how I want my
church to be on
earth here he says yeah
yeah right yeah that's that's
I'm I'm sorry my bad um that's what
absolutely matters no yeah so that's
kind of the thing that I and like I
guess me being non-denominational now I
guess I know now me being
non-denominational is technically a
denomination yeah as you pointed out and
so but that's kind of the thing that
I've uh come to the conclusion like I I
guess it kind of points me back to the
Catholic church and believe it that's
was gonna say if that was your roots and
you didn't study your roots then you did
a disservice by going to another
tradition when without exploring your
own
tradition absolutely and yeah you've
your your studies have helped me a lot I
actually discovered you a few I want to
say like a like a couple like two three
weeks ago and I've just been studying
some of the stuff that you have I don't
want to be repetitive in the stuff
you've already answered but by the way
uh my connection's going down for about
five minutes so I see right here so guys
you may hear my audio but it'll be
choppy because I see okay it's coming
back up go ahead go ahead keep going
okay so um and and that's the whole
thing I I hate that uh God's people have
become so divided with all these
denominations and I think it's of Satan
that we have so many denominations that
there's so many Protestant like I didn't
even know Calvinism was a thing up until
I I watched one of your videos and I
think it's completely ridiculous but but
let me read Jesus's prayer okay John
1720 to 23 here's the heart of Our Lord
I do not ask on behalf of these alone
meaning the disciples but of th of for
those who also believe in me through
their word meaning any believer who
comes to saving Faith through the
apostolic
Ministry I'm praying for them that means
he was praying for us and we'll continue
to pray for all Christians that come to
Salvation through the teachings laid by
the apostles in the power of the Holy
Spirit and preserved that they may all
be one
what is this prayer for all of us to be
one even as you father are in me and I
in you that they also may be in us so
that the world may believe that you sent
me the glory which you have given me I
have given to them that they may be one
just as we are one there are no
divisions disagreements and fighting the
godhead Christ says that's what I want
for my body the church I and them and
you and me that they may be perfected in
unity see their Unity complete and whole
and unbreakable so that the world may
know that you sent me and love me even
as you
have love them as even as You Love Me
Now how many faiths how many baptism how
many bodies watch here Ephesians 4 3-6
how many faiths how many baptisms how
many
churches Ephesians 4: 3-6 right here
being diligent to keep the unity of the
spirit in the bot of Peace you see your
goal my goal your responsible my
responsible is to do everything we can
with the energy given to us to keep our
unity and do it in peace to try to be
Peaceable towards one another fighting
hard to keep an unbreakable Bond a Unity
that comes from being born of The Same
Spirit a Unity that's energized in Us by
the spirit without the spirit we can do
nothing you watch here
there is one body how many bodies one
one Spirit just also as you called in
one hope we all have one hope of your
calling we have one Lord One Faith one
baptism one God and Father of all who's
over all and through all and in all the
Lord never wanted divisions and
denominations never
thank you I I appreciate that because I
I uh I knew there were scripture to
support it I guess I just didn't look
too too hard but and in 1 Corinthians 1:
10:17 Paul rebukes the Christians for
being divided because someone said oh
I'm of Peter I'm of Apollos I'm of Paul
I'm of Christ because what are you guys
talking
about why you divining each other over
personalities and what do you have on
the internet today the cult of
personality oh I'm shunan I love Sam I
like him better than David W oh I'm a
woodan or I'm a diorite or I'm a wiia
you're doing the same thing that Paul
condemned in his lifetime that the
Christians were oh well Peter baptized
me well Paul baptized me oh yeah well I
like Sam Shimon he's better than David
wood well William alre he's much you're
doing that when
you pit us against each
other that's why I say as much as you
love me don't let me to the point where
you idolize me and make me I'm I'm going
to make mistakes and you're going to see
my mistakes and say you know what I
don't agree with Sam there I'll pray
from
good if you think my theology is perfect
then you're deceived man no one on this
side of Glory has perfect theology even
Catholics don't believe that about the
pope and in the Catholic Church there's
not a higher authority than the pope on
Earth he's the head we don't believe no
one believes that the Patriarchs the
Bishops are always Flawless in what they
say no no that doesn't work so
stop swearing by men because I see some
of the people comments about me God
destroy every form of idolatry Blas me
from us and guard my heart not to want
that attention because I'm a sinner
myself then I see how people talk about
other people it's like they can say no
wrong do no wrong come on guys the Lord
says do not give that Allegiance anyone
on Earth so point
being God called you to One
Faith one baptism and he called you to
be part of one
body so then your duty is to seek that
ancient church and brother historically
come on even those who don't like the
Catholic Church even the Orthodox who
reject the claim of the papist you say
yeah the bishop of Rome goes back to the
time of the Apostles he was appointed by
the apostles then they say well then he
lost his
weight given that still
admitting that the bishop of Rome goes
back to the apostles as the bishop of
Alexander Egypt as the bishop of Antioch
Syria as the bishop of Jerusalem as the
bishop of Constantino these were all
seed established by the apostles